I think the message to the consumer is
it but we're just talking about it to be
aware that you have a better sense of I
feels like word-of-mouth marketing or
neuro marking the ways that marketers
are formalizing some of these
technologies and fields of psychology to
to get to us better to understand us
better so just the awareness of how
brands are reaching out to us for for
executives in the business world the
message was clear to me from the
beginning which is quit thinking about
your brand the brand is a result it's
not a tactic you know your brand is like
a shadow you cast on the market and if
you're focused on making good products
you're focused on meeting customer needs
and staying ahead of trends and kind of
getting out there and understanding your
audience you'll have a good brand don't
worry about